[Applause]
i love you it's been way too long
everybody i'd like you to see how long
assaf and i have known each other we go
way back to a film we did together
called music and lyrics yes
which was apparently 15 years ago was it
yeah it seems like actually longer i
don't know why but like in a good way no
it's like i can't belie it flies by it's
just like yeah i have such fun memories
of that film
you just had so much fun on that movie
too i'm such a great person i love mark
lawrence the director and huber
he was always like having like he was
like a grumpy uncle yeah i mean he's
like he's not you you want him to be
warm and fuzzy he's not but then you end
up falling in love with the ring
he's so great he's so he's very witty
very sharp but i remember i met him and
i said i said some movie that he did and
i was like did you have fun doing that
movie and he looked at me he was like
fun
do you have fun
i don't think i ever have fun and i was
like that's so cute i know
it's just too much
well let's talk about your new show
would i lie to you yeah tell us about
the show i've watched some of it it's
basically it's it's uh uh based on a
british show called what i lie to you
which has been on for like 14 years and
we we made the american version and uh
it's basically celebrities coming on and
telling stories from their life which
are personal sometimes embarrassing
and they have to
those stories they they read the card
and that story is either a lie or it's
the truth about their life and they have
to convince the other team
that it's a lie if it's true and vice
versa
it's such a great concept it's so funny
and we got great people who were telling
just outrageous stories well i think
this show is going to be really fun for
people it's on the cw it's really
exciting you have great guests and um
[Applause]
[Music]
you